good morning thank you all for coming
this morning my name is Philip Howard
together with Jimmy Cayne and Larry mone
we're the co-hosts of this event
Manhattan Institute does a wonderful job
putting on interesting writers and
speakers from time to time they don't
often do it in the morning I think with
this turnout and it will see more
morning events in the future
Jimmy Cayne is the CEO of Bear Sterns
and a great friend of Michael a Dean's
and cooked up this idea and has funded
it and has been a big supporter of bold
ideas from time to time and Michael
Levine is certainly a person with bold
ideas
Michael is resident scholar the American
Enterprise Institute made the mistake of
working in government from time to time
it's been accused of being a spy his a
wife much tougher than he is but his
life has led him and his work to admire
the great thinkers of the past and one
of the greatest of these is Machiavelli
one of the things one of the great
things about the country we live in it's
a country founded on principles
unfortunately we've gotten the idea in
this century that applying principles is
a mechanical task it is not it's much
more complicated than that
Machiavelli understood that and Michael
has written an extremely brilliant and
well-written easy-to-read book applying
the principles of Machiavelli to this
century and I look forward to hearing
him describe it more to us Michael Dean
so could I have the book back please no
it's because no I mean it's Phil's book
but it's just that I need to read a
couple of things from it in the course
of these remarks thank you all for
coming out early in the morning I'll
remind you that we have c-span here so
when it's your turn watch your language
I want to thank as I've been thanking
for the last 40 years Jimmy and Paddy
Caine for being such great friends as
you will see when you read Machiavelli a
modern leadership Jimmy is in some part
the inspiration for this book and that
is because in addition to the public
life which all of you know well about
him Running Bear Sterns
he has a private life which is what
really matters and that is as a card
player is a bridge player and there are
some digressions in here and I'll start
with this digression because it's
important there's a whole cult in the
world particularly people who think and
write about either business or
geopolitics which turn out to be the
same kind of reasoning which has it that
chess is somehow the model of life and
that people who are good at chess are
good at life and Charles Krauthammer who
was I don't know if he's a good chess
player but he's an avid chess player I
recently wrote a very important a little
op-ed piece in which he pointed out that
chess players are in fact terrible at
life and that one of the worst things
that can possibly happen to a country is
to get a chess player in charge of it
and I'm sure that's true of companies
too I haven't really done a list but one
of the nice things about bridge players
is that bridge players are terrific
leaders and and managers and I mean
quite aside from places like Bear
Stearns for which bridge pairing is a
requirement
of entry at all positions an
understanding of bridge and worship of
bridge players is essential to advance
card players are great leaders and the
reason for that is that bridge is really
the game that resembles life and card
playing resembles life in a way that
boards don't in board games you see
everything it's all out there there's no
mystery about chess or go or board games
generally you see where all the pieces
are it's just a question of who plays
better and in go that is so rigorous
that weaker players get additional
stones to start with because the good
player is bound to win anyhow it's just
skill in bridge in poker and almost all
card games most of the deck is secret
from you you don't see it you have to
guess at it whether it's guessing what's
going to be given to you if you draw a
card in poker or whether you're guessing
at what your partner and your opponents
have in bridge you have to deduce it
from the bidding and in the course of
that bidding or betting in card games
you face the basic decisions that all
leaders face in the real world about
communication and about passing of
information and today the front page
story in The New York Times is about
espionage which is discovery of
information and leaders always have to
answer the following questions if I tell
my friends and allies everything then my
enemies will find it out too and might
it not be more dangerous to my enemies
than useful to my friends so it might be
best to try to deceive my enemies but if
I lie to my enemies I risk deceiving my
friends and might it not be more
dangerous to deceive my friends than to
deceive my enemies and so on and so
forth and these are the real decisions
that leaders face in the real world and
those are decisions that pertain to card
games and never to board games because
they're just not part of board games so
I wanted to start right here and now and
explain to you why Machiavelli a modern
leadership praises card players not
board players and what does it have to
do with Machiavelli well he was a card
player he held this terrific job at
and the Republic of Florence which is a
kind of combination of chief of staff
and national security adviser to the
second to the to the head of the
Republic and at a certain point he was
fired arrested tortured found innocent
and then sentenced to a year of sort of
internal exile but outside politics have
to stay in the area Florence but
couldn't do politics so what did he do
well he started writing that is why he
wrote that is when he wrote The Prince
and it is in that period that we start
to hear from him about his private life
and in the most famous letter of all
time as special in - grazie hazard where
Machiavelli describes his day and at the
end of which he says and then when the
Sun sets I take off my muddy clothes and
hang them up and put on my regal robes
and talk to the great minds of antiquity
and they answer my questions and I'm
writing down their answers in the little
book on principalities earlier in that
letter he describes how after he's
gotten finished fighting with the
peasants who were trying to cheat him on
the price of his wood and his and his
crops on his land he goes to the inn and
spends the afternoon playing cards and
Machiavelli was a card player and no
question that his understanding of card
games played a role in his understanding
of diplomacy and of the use of
information in a million ways so that's
one reason why I love Machiavelli
because he's like me he's a card player
and he understands all that and being a
card player he understands the role of
luck which is something that a lot of
very smart people don't and one of the
great things about Machiavelli today
today is that it sort of clears away a
lot of the garbage that we have in the
intellectual universe mostly from people
calling themselves sociologists and
political scientists people who think
that you can explain things by
structures a position with which
Machiavelli has no patience at all the
most common phrase that you find in
Machiavelli's writing if you start
asking questions about why do people
behave what happens if all of these
questions that we like to ask of
political philosophers and political
thinkers
his most common response is well it all
depends depends depends on what kind of
society this depends on the quality of
the leaders depends on the history of
the place how did it get there because
the history is everything and he knows
that life is constant change that
anytime you try to take a snapshot of
something and try to define it that way
you're doomed because nothing ever stays
the same and he's talking about the
period between the late 15th and early
16th centuries he's living at the turn
of that century which we do not think of
as a period of very rapid change
certainly compared to today and yet he
insisted that no person no organization
no structure no team no state ever Stood
Still it was either going up or going
down and if you didn't drive it up it
was going to drag itself down by its own
nature human nature for Machiavelli
being a very grim subject you've all
read some of it man is that animal who
is more inclined to do evil than to do
good that's the basic rule look around
you who are your colleagues who are your
employees who are your electors who are
the other people in the world around you
these are all people ready to get you
and want to get you that's why they're
there they would much rather do evil
into good they would much rather hurt
you than help you and he insists on this
over and over again and from this
derives all the basic principles and
helps to eliminate all the nonsense I
was just thinking listening to the news
today how shocked people are to discover
that the Chinese and most everybody else
are trying to steal our military secrets
why it wasn't more than 10 years ago
that we were being told by all the smart
people that military things didn't
matter anymore that all that business
about war and military power that was
old hat the Cold War was over we had now
entered a period of peace and henceforth
it was going to be money and Commerce
and trading abilities and things like
that that we're going
that we're going to matter those were
going to be the factors that we're going
to dominate the world for the
foreseeable future so why are all these
people busily stealing secrets about
nuclear warheads if what really matters
is money and products and training and
commerce and the answer is that those
warheads actually matter quite a bit you
can have all the commerce and money that
you want somebody has a bigger warhead
than you do you're going to have to pay
attention to them and twas ever thus and
he explains also the reason he explains
how we got into the mindset of being
willing to believe that military doesn't
matter anymore and Armed Forces don't
count and military morale doesn't matter
we can use the Armed Forces for
anthropological experiments to see how
long military morale can survive
co-educational tents in Bosnia and other
interesting questions which we are
exploring nowadays in contemporary
America he explains it he says good
leaders and particularly great leaders
always incarnate military virtues they
are just like military commanders and
the virtues of the military commander
are the virtues of the great leader this
brings a terrible risk to free societies
because a lot of times those great
leaders are not tolerant and aren't
inclined to give people a lot of room to
move around and in those periods when we
judge that we're not at great threat and
we don't have to take the risk of having
such people in leadership positions we
prefer people who are much less
threatening logical enough and so he
says it's almost impossible to get good
leadership in peacetime and if you take
a look back at most any the history of
most any country you care to study you
will find that this rule applies with
almost mathematical precision the case
of Churchill is the easiest one to think
about Churchill was one of the great
leaders of the 20th century one of the
great men of the 20th century the minute
the war was over the British dumped him
now
because they didn't know he was a great
leader but we said precisely because
they knew he was a great leader and they
didn't want a man like that during
peacetime they wanted some guy who was
just going to sort of bumble around and
wasn't going to constantly give them
speeches about fighting on the beaches
and fighting in the streets and all this
other stuff they wanted to put that all
behind them as we say nowadays so the
military virtues turnout from
Machiavelli to be indispensable at the
end to saving good Republic's and good
organizations of any sort
which brings us to the really serious
things that he talks about Machiavelli
to my great surprise and you know
anytime you write a book it always turns
out to be different from the book you
had in your mind when you sat down to
write it the last thing in the world
that I expected when I sat down to do
Machiavelli was to spend a lot of time
writing about religion because I had not
expected that this would be such a
central theme for Machiavelli but indeed
it turns out that it is and his great
hero was Moses and in the early months
when I was writing this book Washington
has lots of interesting cocktail parties
and the basic question in Washington is
always what do you do which is a way of
finding out whether they need to worry
about you or pay attention to you in
case you're the assistant secretary of
something or other and so when people
say what do you do I would say well I'm
writing this book of Machiavelli and
from time to time people would actually
say why and my answer was well he
reminds you of all these basic things
that we've forgotten like what and I
said well like you know Moses killing
all those Jews at Mount Sinai and almost
universally people would say what are
you talking about because this is the
stuff that Rockefeller loves that most
people have forgotten having seen the
movie instead of reading the book and
the this is the scene that Golden Calf
most people think what happens is that
Moses comes down from Sonny's got the
tab
this idolatry is going on he throws us
snit smashes the tablets and then they
calm him down and after some period of
time when he calms down he goes back up
and gets a new set of tablets and then
they move on which is not what happens
what happens is he throws the snit
smashes the tablets and then says kill
them all and the levites and I pay
attention to this being one it's but you
know I'm proud of this particular
passage the Levites come and kill them
all all those people were worshiping the
golden calf
except Aaron from who somehow escaped
because he had to preserve his DNA for
the lembeh tribe in southern Africa so
and this scene of Moses killing Jews
recurs several times in the Old
Testament and Machiavelli pays close
attention to it producing one of his
most famous lines which is anybody
looking carefully at Moses has to admit
that in order to create a new state and
a new religion had to kill countless
people and he insists on this that in
order to create anything truly
meaningful destruction is required
because people are not inclined to go
for that
I mean considered the Exodus that that's
top-notch leadership Moses and God hard
to imagine better leadership than that
plus proven results every step of the
way plagues parting of the Red Sea
lights at night across the desert manna
falling from the skies when you're
hungry everything possible and what's
the reaction of the Jews always that the
first opportunity they're ready to go
back to Egypt and that had that happens
repeatedly when they get finally to the
boundaries of the Promised Land I'd like
to remind people with this because it's
the model of today they everybody is
very annoyed today that these formerly
communist countries are taking so they
don't seem to get it about capitalism
and democracy why can't they understand
freedom well that's what Exodus is all
about and it's what market value is all
about it's why he's fascinated by this
stuff what happens they get to the
boundaries
the promised land they organized an
espionage operation Joshua and Caleb and
38 other people go in and snoop around
and come back and report good news and
bad news good news even better than God
said milk and honey everywhere beautiful
fabulous a dream
bad news these people are bigger than we
are they're superbly well defended and
there is no way no way that we're going
to beat these people and they riot and
this is the usual insurrection against
Moses and they demand proper leadership
people who will take them back to Egypt
back to Egypt at which point God says to
Moses well you know I can't take this
anymore I'm going to kill them all and
we'll and we'll take yeah you and Joshua
and a couple of the other guys who seem
to be alright and we'll start all over
again
because with these people it's hopeless
you know they're worse than the Serbs
and and Moses talked them out of it as
usual it says no no no they'll be
alright they'll be right and God says ok
but but now one of these people is ever
going to set foot and the promised land
we're going to wait for them all to die
and then it will give their children a
chance maybe they'll get it and it is
that is the basic rule the Machiavelli
has long sections on transitions between
freedom and tyranny between democracy
and dictatorship between free
organizations and dictatorial ones and
he says everything works I mean anything
can work my grandmother was a great
political philosopher he used to say
best government Goods our worst
government Bad's are more bad czars than
good czars
which is the basic theory of democracy
all right the best democracy is never
going to be as good as the best
enlightened despotism nothing is so good
as an enlightened despotism but it's a
very unreliable unstable form of
governments and you pay a terrible price
for it and the odds are that after an
enlightened
tater you get a whole series of rotten
dictators so democracy's better and he
grants that but he says it's very hard
to move back and forth from one to
another because once a people has been
subjected to tyranny for a long time
they cannot think as free people anymore
which was the case of the Jews they
could not think the street people
Russians who spent the better part of
this century under tyranny cannot think
as free people their children might be
able to learn to think as free people
having not been raised in the habits of
slaves and similarly people who have
been free for a very long time it's very
hard to extirpate
free instincts as we have discovered for
example in the cases of Poland Czech
Czech Republic Hungary and so forth they
were very briefly enslaved and they
never lost that mentality and
Machiavelli and the prince gives
instructions to a would-be tyrant and I
want to explain that briefly and then we
can talk for a bit gives instructions to
would be tyranny said if you take over a
state that has been free and the people
in it have been free people you have
only two possibilities the one is kill
them all and the other is to scatter
them so that physically that population
no longer has any sense of cohesion and
I in collective identity because there's
no other way otherwise they will always
scheme against you they will always find
a time to strike in you because they
will never lose the habits of free
people well this is the kind of thing
that Machiavelli is famous for unjustly
famous for that kind of remark because
the prince in fact is not what he wanted
in life he wanted free societies he
preferred free societies he was the high
official of one of the freest societies
in the Europe of the late 15th and early
16th centuries why did he write the
prince he wrote the prince because he
had learned that what wrecks everything
always is corruption leaders become
corrupt and they become corrupt
precisely at there at the moment of
their greatest triumph that's when the
rot sets in
because when you're clawing your way up
the ladder trying to take over trying to
defeat your enemies virtue generally
obtains because you have to observe that
near military virtue in order to get
yourself to the top in order to defeat
these people once you've won and you can
settle back and live the good life and
get the rewards that you deserve and
that you've earned having fought your
way up there along with all those
rewards in the good life comes indolence
sloth corruption self-indulgence all the
very things that are wrecking us today I
mean come to Washington you will see a
level of self-indulgence corruption
sloth I've lived in Washington now for
22 years and I have never seen anything
like it
it's really quite unbelievable and the
general indifference with which this
corruption is viewed would suggest that
the corruption is spreading that's not
just limited to the corrupt leaders but
that it's spreading down to their
various followers and this in fact is
what has happened in Machiavelli's
forints he looked around and saw a
cesspool of corruption and he wrote
descriptions of corruption and what
happens to people who are corrupt which
are unlike anything though that we will
find in contemporary literature even the
most violent Clinton haters never
approach this kind of thing I wanna see
if I can find it for you and here's what
happens it's an almost perfect
description of us today he's writing
about ancient Rome the Romans were
secure of their Liberty and did not see
any enemies who could frighten them this
security and the weakness of their
enemies induced the Romans to name
consuls not on the basis of virtue but
of popularity elevating to those high
offices men who knew how to charm the
people not those who knew how to defeat
their enemies then later from those most
charming they descended to those most
powerful so that the good men were
completely excluded that's and there's
no escape from these
was I must tell you there's no escape
from it once you start on this path the
Machiavelli's desperate question was how
do you stop it what do you do with the
state with an organization with the
football team whatever it may be that
has fallen into this kind of rod and he
thought he thought and he said the only
thing I can think of is a temporary
dictatorship you have to find somehow a
good dictator who will be willing to do
the terrible things the evil things that
are necessary to drag this thing up out
of the swamp and install a virtuous free
society for a generation and then hope
that it sticks that it takes and he said
I don't know of a single case where this
has worked but it's the only cure that I
can think of and so he wrote the prince
which is a kind of want ad wanted good
man willing to do evil things for a
generation to save the soul of the
nation that's what the princes and he
lays down the rules that this guy is
going to have to follow if he's going to
save us now in fact he was right he was
right er than he knew because we have
done this anytime you talk about this to
Americans they always go oh my god you
know the temporary dictatorship too high
a price to pay
we did it to Germany and Japan at the
end of World War two it's exactly what
we did we imposed a military
dictatorship on those two former
tyrannies and we purged those societies
and we made everybody fess up to what
they had done during the Nazi period not
as much as we might have but it was
enough and we impose democracy on them
we ran it we picked their leaders we put
them in office we screens their
followers and people held all high
positions particularly in the military
we wrote the Japanese Constitution we
virtually wrote the German constitution
and we imposed virtue on those places
Turkey has done that on at least two
occasions in this century first when
audits are
dated modern Turkey at the end of the
First World War and then again when
Turkey was subjected to this horrible
wave of terrorism in the 1970s when the
generals took over I mean they had
achieved a rate of killing unique in
modern history I forget where there was
six people a minute or one person every
six minutes but those are the numbers of
people being killed by terrorists and
Turkey before the military set up its
most recent dictatorship and then they
said once we clean this up we're going
to turn it back over to the civilians
which they did so it works so I can't
think of any better way to go out but I
mean I can't resist reading
Machiavelli's description of Clinton and
then I'll stop and we'll talk because
it's a-you know he's amazing say 176 he
wrote about the the leaders of Florence
just before they were knocked off by the
Medicis coming back they thought he said
that it suffice for a prince and the
writing rooms of palaces to think up a
sharp reply to write a beautiful letter
to demonstrate wit and retinas and
saying and words to know how to weave a
fraud to keep many lascivious women
around to conduct himself avaricious ly
and proudly to rot in idleness to give
military rank by favor to be scornful if
any one might show them any praiseworthy
path to want their words to be or
regular responses nor did these no
accounts realize that they were
preparing themselves to be the prey of
whoever assaulted them and that's our
bill and that is the most perfect
description and analysis of Clinton and
the threat he poses to America that has
ever been written and it was written 500
years ago by this delightful little guy
and I hope you read the book and enjoy
it thanks
yeah sterile balls being a good bridge
player I love first place good the
Romans had no enemies
is their parallel between America when
the Soviet Union was very powerful and
what's happened ever since they become
unhelpful there are no enemies equals to
us right now yeah sure that's exactly
that's exactly the right parallel
because once you don't have enemies once
you don't feel threatened
once you have no challenge in your life
then you go soft and you become
self-indulgent and corrupt and we're
becoming self-indulgent and corrupt but
it's in it's unforgivable in the case of
countries particularly the world's lone
superpower because it means not only
that you've given in to this kind of
corruption which can happen to anybody
and Machiavelli do it knew it well he
gave in to it whenever possible but it
means that you've forgotten the basic
rules of life which is that while you
may not see your next enemy you may be
confident that he is there because he's
always there you just haven't noticed
and so you always have to be ready for
the next time because that's the one
thing you can be sure of that that's the
most certain thing in life that the next
time is going to come after you yeah for
my place no I don't want a dictatorship
I think that what we have is a corrupt
leadership in America I don't think we
have a corrupt country if if and when it
ever happens that the country becomes
thoroughly corrupt then I think probably
the only solution to it would be the
kind of temporary dictatorship that
Machiavelli talked about because I don't
see any other solution today it's quite
easily just vote out the corrupt people
and vote in some virtuous ones as we've
done so many times in the past this is
not the first time that we've had
corrupt leadership tonight
States you think it's only the leader
yeah I think the public is basically
sane and sensible as far as I can tell I
mean the instincts of the American
people invariably seem healthy to me
yeah in the public come to its
realization without a military threat
can the public come to the realization
without a military threat yes I mean
it's although our history is very
discouraging on this score because
America in the 20th century was
torpedoed into World War one by Germany
bombed into World War two by June was
demobilizing a mile a minute before the
onset of the Cold War which was kicked
off primarily by Stalin's actions in
Turkey Greece and Iran and we would have
demobilized to a fare-thee-well at the
end of the Cold War if Saddam Hussein
hadn't intervened just in time to keep
our military spending level up and says
to put our military back in the field
our instincts as American people believe
I have always believed that peace is the
normal condition of mankind
it's a conceit almost unique to
Americans nobody else in the world that
I know of believes that because most
everybody else is studying history which
we don't and so you know we think that
peace is normal and so when the war is
over we you know all those slogans we
bring the boys home we you know the guns
to butter and all those other things we
like to do and then comes another crisis
and we have to gear up all over again
it's terribly inefficient and silly but
there we are and you know probably won't
change so we probably need some kind of
you know somebody needs to do something
to us for us to take these things
seriously I don't know whether Chinese
spies are enough probably not I would
guess not China's a very long way away
you know yeah
well pee that's a good question is
pinochet such a virtuous temporary
dictator I'm not sure that Chile fits
that model in the first place and I'm
not sure that the problem in Chile at
the time with Pinochet was corruption so
probably not the way the Turks and the
Americans at the end of World War two
fit that model so I think probably not
but I mean Pinochet is a guy was
certainly entitled to at worst mix
reviews a nasty dictator a nasty
dictator who you know won a civil war
and did then several good things
thereafter particularly for those people
think economic factors of paramount I
mean Pinochet on economics and Social
Policy was really very good in Chile
became a model for the rest of Latin
America I myself think political things
are more important than economic thing
so I'm more critical of Pinochet than
those people look basically at the
economic stuff so no I don't think
Pinochet is a pure case of the virtuous
dictator
you know right help me understand what's
going on in the Far East
do you take China which has a
dictatorship and plenty of corruption we
contrast that to Japan which does expose
idli has a democracy very little
corruption Ohno Japan the Japan is in
the running of most corrupt country in
the world are you kidding Japan is so
corrupt that look I mean a few years ago
when when Japanese industry and
corruption were really booming I thought
I mean I spent half my life in Italy I
lived in Rome for ten years so you know
we know a thing or two about corruption
at my family but the but the Japanese
make the Italians look like pikers
there's not a single Italian scandal in
the last 50 years that begins to compare
to almost any of the Japanese scandals I
mean Japan is just a sea of
since Japan is phenomenally correct I
don't know what's more corrupt maybe
Russia but maybe but it's but it's a
battle because there's more money in
Japan than in Russia so how do they get
it
how do who get out of it the Chinese I'm
not sure the Chinese are going to get
out of it I mean China is a very
explosive country and it's not just that
I mean the people know the government's
corrupt everybody knows the government's
corrupt everybody knows the business
there is party SH and all the rest of it
and they have what is it a hundred
million or 200 million nomads wandering
around
they have oppressed peoples on the on
the margins and not such margins
you know such one and Mongolia and Tibet
and all those people all hate the Han
and don't want to be dominated by and so
forth that is very tough well it could
blow up it could implode it could do
what the Soviet empire did and the
Chinese leaders who have studied what
happened to the Soviet empire very
attentively much more carefully than we
have they constantly say we are not
going to make the mistakes that the
Russians made by which they mean they're
not going to give freedom to their
people because they saw that once you
give these your freedom to these people
they don't appreciate you
in gratitude Machiavelli says most
common human attitude right they don't
remember all the good things that Mao
did for them and Tong Xiao ping that
great bridge player swimming for the
body bridge of the mind writing it's
great line and so they'll throw them out
and they know that and so far at least
the Chinese like Castro kill anybody who
stands up and says hey why don't we vote
on this and as long as they will do that
they will remain in power the minute you
find a generation of leaders the
Gorbachev's who look in the mirror and
instead of seeing the incarnation of the
world's historical idea or alternatively
the person God put on earth to guide the
destiny of the world at this moment in
history sees just another guy trying
very hard to do his job then it'll go
down
but it won't go down until that happens
it's all a question of leadership as he
says yeah I think I've probably
misunderstood you but let me try this
out and see where I'm wrong man is
basically evil therefore peace is an
unnatural state of being and will lead
to corruption and decay thus good
leaders must keep us in a constant state
of war no no it's that thus that's not
there now thus therefore statecraft that
therefore leaders and what leaders must
do is to restrain those impulses and to
tame that a all those evil instincts
because man is more inclined to do evil
than to do good but man can do not only
good but great glory is possible it's
happened and and and furthermore yeah
just let me just finish this one thought
and furthermore he has it on divine
authority he never gives you a footnote
but he says over and over again God
believes that the highest thing a man
can do is to advance his nation and to
do good for his nation state craft is
the highest calling and he says that in
order again to lure at least one guy out
of early retirement who will do these
evil things to save Florence because he
keeps saying don't worry it's true you
have to do all these evil things but you
will not go to hell a result of it
because God cherishes above all things
great leaders yeah but I don't if I
could the the an extension of peace of
peaceful times leads as you say to two
levels of corruption levels of decay
within society and the only way to purge
that is to to have a strong leader come
in and either kill a lot of people or or
create a war like situation that will
will will will purge that decay and no
Howard don't get carried away I mean the
prince the the the prince is only
required at its moments of extreme
corruption I mean the prince is a crisis
response document I mean
the because he thought there was
hopeless because he thought it was all
Gordon it wasn't just the leaders it was
the people it was the institution's it
was the church the whole thing so it's a
it's a desperation move and it says I
don't know of a single case that's ever
worked no I mean most of the time you
just replace corrupt leaders with good
ones and then that'll work right
I mean you hire Pat Riley and he makes
the team go all right that's how to do
it yeah and then there's people in the
my teams to me I mean there are several
leaders who are practicing today and who
are masters of state who have eliminated
who very enables political manipulations
all of their opposition wanted Saddam
Hussein when it's bullosa [ __ ] if you
go to China you hear the argument that
Americans want democracy human rights
everything but the biggest danger the
Chinese feel to themselves is disorder
and so they feel that they have to have
a powerful centralized dictatorial
government right but in fact they're far
more corrupt and far less powerful than
we are here and if you take in contrast
Thomas Jefferson who said if the public
is too ignorant to govern itself the
solution is to educate the public about
to take its power yes well you don't
have to convince either me or
Machiavelli on any of those points right
he agrees with all of them and so do i
but it seems to me all the people that
have put this policy I mean is this idea
into practice have ended up with
weakened countries that were ultimately
destroyed but his when you keep leaving
out the key concept which is virtue like
if le is not advocating tyranny for
tyranny sake
he hates tyrannies he thinks it's the
worst form of government to end the
least stable so they're all for - he is
advocating in desperation in the prince
a temporary dictator because without it
he doesn't see any way to preserve
freedom in his in
in his Italy so it's a desperation move
it's not what he wants you see all of us
were taught this wrong in school because
the prince is a handy short little book
and we can all get through that the
discourses and the rest of it are big
long fat books and hard to deal with
seem to be rough seem to be involved he
said we need a powerful man in charge
yes but yeah well then Machiavelli tells
you why he's wrong because it's a very
bad form of government and you should
turn to it only as an act of extreme
desperation and I don't see anything in
America that would lead someone to
conclude that we're in that situation I
mean we do need virtuous leaders that we
do and I think most people agree with
that nowadays there was someone in the
back there it's hard to see past the
lights yeah just curious political views
who you think is out there my candidate
i-i don't have a candidate I haven't had
a candidate for a very long time I mean
there isn't anybody out there that
particularly you know enthuses me yeah
the people in New York who are generally
liberal sense what they're saying when
they turn to Rudy Giuliani for a sort of
strong leadership and certainly it's
surprising to find that New Yorkers
would fight him acceptable because
they're so intolerant of any sort of
strength so why do liberal why have
liberal New Yorkers embrace Giuliani if
they have you know I don't live here so
I can't attest to that but I would guess
that the reason is that New Yorkers know
from long experience that the city works
best with an Italian mayor and I don't
think I don't think you have to look
more deeply than that yeah there was
someone back there yes speak it seems to
me that the thesis that you are
representing places no value on the
individual you talk about the state you
talk about killing seems like the the
Sargent was court-martialed for me like
really had the answer you got to kill
everybody off in order to find a
solution now how do you reconcile the
philosophy of this country regardless of
who's running it with the fundamental
faith that we place in individual and
perhaps confidence that Aristotle was
correct when he said that man is a
social animal I well mark you village
does not think that man is a political
animal
I stack let's stack Aristotle against
Machiavelli for a minute well you're
entitled you know if you want to don't
you feel there's a legitimate ethical
base to assert the rights and the values
of human human rights and the values of
the individual well I can't imagine
what I have said here this morning which
would have led you to this peculiar
conclusion sir to tell you the truth
since the subject has never come up and
I thought it was clear enough from
several remarks that I made and
quotations I gave you from Machiavelli
that what he's after above all is
freedom and that is not a collective
concept that is an individual concept so
he agrees with you he wants individual
freedom
I mean who understood it better than he
living at a time of the greatest
individual creativity in history before
the 20th century the Italian Renaissance
so he agrees with that not to worry it's
safe for you to read and for your
children to read he's and he's fully in
favor of virtue and freedom and and
Christian morality which he says is the
way we all ought to live our lives it's
just that if you're going to be a leader
he says then you had better be prepared
from time to time to enter into evil
because you are going to be faced with
situations in which you must choose
between behaving ethically and losing
and entering into evil in order to win
and if you're not willing to enter into
evil in order to win then you're in the
wrong game and you better go do
something else which is fine with him he
just doesn't want some leader he doesn't
want Jimmy Carter right he doesn't want
some guy going to Poland and telling a
communist dictator you know I haven't
given up on bringing you back to
Christianity that is not the kind of
leader he's looking for he is looking
for someone who's willing to do nasty
things to the Soviet empire to bring it
down because the survival of the nation
is at stake and he's looking for a
leader who is not going to act blase
when it turns out that every nuclear
warhead in our inventory has been turned
over to communist China and have them
say well you know I can reassure I can
assure the American people that you know
our nuclear secrets are being well
protected when in fact every nuclear
secret we have has been turned over to
the Chinese he wants leadership that
will take the common good seriously
because he knows that leaders
who are self-indulgence and corrupt
cannot think in terms of the common good
let me say he has a statement here which
really takes your breath away he says
look corrupt and self-indulgent leaders
never use military power correctly they
can't because they always use it as a
kind of prop for their own personal
glory they posed against it they like
you know the troops on parade when they
sent an army into the field he says they
always instruct that army never to fight
a battle above all to avoid direct
contact with the enemy don't fight a
battle because that may go badly and
then the leader will look bad now you
look at Clinton and you ask yourself how
can it be that every time we are
challenged by whatever country under
whatever circumstances he never ever
sends American military forces to bring
down that regime which is the normal
response right he didn't try to bring
down Saddam Hussein he isn't trying to
bring down Milosevic he didn't try to
bring down anybody but he was just sort
of said people there to look good and
keep things cool or to launch the cruise
missile being the weapon of choice
because it's a nice safe weapon for us
and shoot it from a great distance and
then just hurt them
or drop bombs from planes and high
altitudes never engage the enemy well it
keeps casualties down on our side but it
also ensures that you will have no
victory because as the Gulf War reminded
us it's very hard to surrender to an
airplane the I mean the the Iraqis would
have surrendered to anything they
surrendered to journalists as soon as
they saw something that looked like an
American they said oh thank god where
have you been can we surrender now but
you can't surrender to a plane you can't
only surrender to a guy so you have to
put people on the ground if only for
that sir
external friends how do in or do in the
girl threat
example you look New York on or run a
folks about two-thirds kids and State
kid as these very English proficiency
gas right serious internal
well you can fit anything you want to
into my thesis I'm sure you know if this
keeps up I said to st. Martin's the
other day I'm going to end up by writing
an op-ed piece on you know a
Machiavellian the Baltimore Orioles I
mean you can force it in but look I mean
for Machiavelli culture was just
fundamental and and what all he would
say on the subject is that without
culture the society just isn't going to
survive at all so you had better have
leadership that takes the education of
the people seriously and well you know I
don't want to start down this path
because Manhattan Institute is sort of
ranking expert in this fields and they
can tell you all their people can tell
you all about that but I mean obviously
we've been diddled by all series of
phony standards and phony missions and
education for a very long time and so
we're buried under a morass now of
cultural debris it's going to be very
hard to clear it away it's very tough
yeah
during sex involved the Newman Nitra
just one situation after another and
that if you had to describe all of this
the tendency is that you know using in
terms of Wall Street that human nature
would be a sell well yes
have you I mean I have a doctorate in
history so I don't find this idea
shocking at all but I mean how would you
characterize human history the sweep of
human history there's certainly more bad
news than good isn't there and the 20th
century is olds all records I was also
in case of Bosnia State and and you
mentioned Bosnia in the Persian Gulf in
in defense of what's going on today I'd
say it's a little unfair to say that the
US Army going into Bosnia when it's
really unprepared to go into Bosnia
because I don't believe the United
States Army could take losses that it
would possibly sustain in Bosnia in this
in its current condition would require
something that a mission that the US
Army cannot perform so I think the
reason why our politicians are avoiding
that situation is is our army really is
a is a paper shell as far as a ground
force goes well I don't have the
slightest doubt that the American armed
forces could destroy the Serbian army in
relatively short order under a variety
of different scenarios I have no doubt
at all that had we decided to be serious
about saving Kosovars
and preserving Kosovo from Serbia knock
you patient and destruction that all we
had to do was send in our Special Forces
before the bombing campaign started to
kill the mobile killing squads mean the
one point of comparison that I accept
between Nazi Germany and Serbia is those
mobile killing squads which are replicas
and probably based on the Nazi
Einsatzgruppen during the Second World
War said this is a textbook operation
for Special Forces and we have superb
forces and so do the British and so do
the French and so do the Germans and so
do the Italians all these groups trained
with one another they know one another
they have competitions with each other
their codes are exchangeable their
communications are interchangeable it
would have been a very simple matter
very simple matter to take out those
things we own you know miles the earth
class at Fort Benning and after that
experience I can tell you I tend to
disagree with him well you may be right
I always say I did counterterrorism for
several years and I went to these
training exercises and I have watched
those guys perform and you should ask
yourself why precision weapons are so
precise and the answer is because there
are homing devices in the targets that
they hit and it took people to go there
and put those homing devices in those
targets and those are special forces and
they worked in Iraq and they work in
Belgrade and I mean those guys are very
good and very brave and very tough and
they go in and out and nobody sees them
and we're talking about I mean those
mobile killing units that the Serbs have
been using in Kosovo you're talking
about twenty thirty forty people at a
time these are not big these are not big
pitched battles yeah but I mean it's
just not real all right oh sure that he
spent his whole life trying to teach
leadership
um that's the first time I've heard that
question and I don't know the answer my
guess is that he would say that there
are some people are just too stupid to
get it but short of that I think he
would think that most people can be can
be trained to do it well that's right
you have to have a flair I mean some
people will have a natural flair for it
and that will be that we have about two
minutes left
so I'll take either one long question or
two real quick questions fell short and
you have a leadership
not according to Machiavelli according
to Machiavelli any good state rests on
good laws good arms and good religion
and without any one of those it just
won't work good arms good laws good
religion and he says that really without
fear of God you can't have an orderly
society impossible tight OG he was a
surprise it was an enormous surprise to
me all of the stuff I didn't expect to
find it I didn't expect to end up
devoting so much time to it and and I
must say that on an awful lot of this
stuff I think he's right
I mean I'm not you know this is not a
book of hero worship it's an exposition
and and it was born and it's a good
place to stop at the American Enterprise
as to we have a wonderful tradition of
Friday brown bag lunches primarily for
interns we have dozens and in the summer
scores of interns from all the best
schools in the country and they come and
do research for us and help us out and
so one of the scholars every Friday
stands up and he modes on whatever he or
she is working on so one day I was
talking about something and I made some
passing reference to something in
Machiavelli and I got a room of blank
faces and I said what's going on here
how many of you have read the prints in
the last four or five years a couple how
many of you who have read the discourses
nobody and I said what's going on so I
picked it up and started to read it and
I thought I understood why which was
that nobody knows who Machiavelli is
talking about when he gives us examples
because he's talking about obscure
ancient Greeks and Romans and Spartans
and Persians or contemporaries of his
that nobody knows nobody even knows who
Caesar Borgia was anymore nowadays
because this stuff is not taught so I
thought well it would be helpful maybe
to do a an edition of Machiavelli with
contemporary examples so people would
know what he's talking about so instead
of Medicis and Borges I have gates and
Buffett and Leo Durocher and Pat Riley
and Gorbachev and Clinton and Reagan
disarming people that we know about and
so far response has been good because
it's much easier to get it when you
think about people that you've already
devoted some time to think about know
who they are than it is with these
obscure people we have to look up of
every single reference in the book so I
hope in this way I've made Machiavelli
more accessible and I would only say
please don't confuse me with Machiavelli
I should be so lucky thanks for coming
up